imagina que vas por la calle y alguien
se acerca a ti y te da la siguiente
expresión x cuadrada más 7 x + 10
dividida por x + 2 y te dice intenta
simplificar esta expresión bueno pausa
el vídeo y ve si puedes hacerlo
una forma de pensarlo es que resulta de
la división de x cuadrada más 7 x + 10
entre x + 2 cuál es el resultado bien
hay dos formas de resolver esto una de
las formas es intentar factorizar el
numerador y ver si el numerador tiene un
factor que es común con el denominador
bien vamos a intentarlo esto lo hemos
hecho varias veces y si esto te parece
nuevo te encargó que revises cómo
factorizar polinomios en otros lugares
de khan academy que números suman 7 y al
multiplicar se dan 10 bueno será 2 y 5
por lo tanto podemos reescribir el
numerador como x más 2 que multiplica a
x + 5 y por supuesto el denominador
sigue siendo x + 2
claramente podemos ver que tenemos un
factor común entonces mientras x no sea
igual a menos 2
que si x es igual a menos 2 toda la
expresión es indefinida porque obtenemos
un 0 en el denominador
entonces mientras x no sea igual a menos
2 podemos dividir el numerador y el
denominador por x + 2 ojo la razón por
la cual pongo esta restricción es que no
podemos dividir el numerador y el
denominador por 0 así que para cualquier
otro valor de x esta parte x + 2 no será
0 y entonces podemos dividir el
numerador y el denominador por eso estos
dos se cancelan y quedarnos sólo con x +
5 así que otra forma de pensarlo es que
esta expresión con la que empezamos se
puede ver como x + 5 para cualquier x
distinta de menos 2
ahora bien la otra forma de resolver
esto es a través de una división
algebraica larga que es análoga a la
división larga que seguramente recuerdas
de la primaria la forma de hacerlo es
decir vamos a dividir x cuadrada más 7 x
+ 10 entre x + 2 y en esta técnica
tienes que trabajar con los términos de
grado mayor tengo x y x cuadrada y decir
cuántas veces cabe x en x cuadrada bueno
cabe x veces y lo escribes en esta
columna ya que x tiene potencia 1 y esta
es la columna de grado 1
esto es análogo al valor de posición del
que hablábamos cuando empiezas a
aprender los números aquí lo puedes ver
según la posición del grado o algo así
entonces a esta x la multiplicas por
toda la expresión de fuera entonces x
por 2 es 2x que pondré en la columna de
primer grado y x por x es ex cuadrada y
lo que vamos a hacer es restar esta
expresión en naranja a la expresión en
azul que bueno teníamos inicialmente lo
haré de esta forma me quedaré con 7 x 2
x lo cual es 5 x y x cuadrada - x
cuadrada es simplemente cero ahora
podemos traer este 10 y una vez más
puedes pensar en los dos términos con
grado mayor
x 5x y x cabe en 5 x 5 veces estamos en
la columna de grado cero de las
constantes y me quedan 5 por 12 es 10 5
por x de 5x y ahora voy a restar lo de
la expresión de arriba observa no
tenemos residuo todo se va y ya está
ahora bien una de las cosas interesantes
de la división polinómica larga que
probablemente veamos en otro vídeo es
que es muy probable que tengas un
residuo justo estas son las situaciones
que la técnica de factorización no puede
resolver en este caso en particular la
forma más fácil de resolverlo es la de
arriba pero esta es otra forma de
pensarlo decir oye x más 2 x x + 5 nos
da x cuadrada más 7 x + 10
ahora si quieres reescribir esta
expresión en la forma en la que lo
hicimos a un lado es decir que esta
expresión es lo mismo que x + 5 entonces
tuvimos que construir la siguiente
restricción en el dominio para todas las
x diferentes de menos 2
y con esto estas dos expresiones son
idénticas